[Music]
[Applause]
he's Mike Florio he's a busy guy pro
football talk live co-host precedes us
with Chris Sims and contributor to
football night in America and he's got a
novel out it's about the mob it's called
father of mine now available pre-order
hitting bookshelves April 25th
where'd that come from
pandemic sitting around doing nothing
pandemic alcohol cigars the Bermuda
Triangle of creativity that should be
the name of the book
what the Bermuda Triangle yes yeah and
pandemic whatever hey whatever happened
to the Bermuda Triangle remember when
that was a thing like any plane that
flew over that area just disappeared any
boat that went over that and then we
just never heard about it again the
Bermuda Triangle ended up in the Bermuda
Triangle I think I need to reach out to
Kyrie Irving and get his thoughts on the
Bermuda Triangle all right Mike we got
uh a busy day here with franchise tag
day explain the Lamar Jackson situation
what are the options for team and
quarterback
well technically first option is do
nothing and let it become a free agent
they're not going to do that option two
would be the transition tag which would
give them a right to match and no
compensation they're not going to do
that it comes down to the franchise tag
there's two levels one it's called the
non-exclusive tag that would result in a
32.4 million dollar one-year contract
for Lamar Jackson if he chooses to
accept it but before he accepts it you
have the ability to go out and talk to
any team he wants as long as they have a
first round pick in 2023 can't talk to
the Dolphins can't talk to the Saints
can talk to anybody with a first round
pick in 23 and 24. could sign an offer
sheet Ravens can match it and then they
finally have a long-term contract with
Lamar or
they can say thanks you take him we'll
take your two first round picks 2023 in
2024. that's not exclusive for 32.4 they
can go exclusive meaning he can't talk
to anybody he's under contract with them
or no one unless they would trade him
that costs 45 million and the key is
year two because if you do a two-year
franchise tag non-exclusive it's 71
million dollars total if you do two-year
exclusive it's 99 million total that's
why it's such a big decision for the
Ravens they're going to open the door to
him possibly leaving
at 32 million for this year or they're
going to slam that door shut and commit
to 45.
is this all about Deshawn Watson if if
Watson doesn't have that deal as Lamar
Jackson signed
well I have a feeling there would be
something else
just because and and look I've I've been
on record from the moment Lamar Jackson
entered the NFL without an agent of all
the positions quarterback needs an agent
you need a great agency that has
experience negotiating complicated
quarterback contracts it's one thing to
do your original contract because it's
all slotted it's easy second contract
tougher and look Dan even if he does a
long-term deal with the Ravens today it
doesn't change the fact that he could
have had one in August and been paid for
all of 2022 based on a higher contract
instead of getting 23 million for the
full season and now being year two of
that big money deal he turned down so
the Watson thing became kind of that
focal point five years fully guaranteed
that's what I want that's what I want
that's what I want and we'll find out if
they go non-exclusive is there a team
out there that is currently that is
ready to go five years fully guaranteed
would the Falcons do it would the
commanders do it yeah I I kind of wonder
whether or not they're just kind of
lurking in the wee needs Baltimore's
close by hey we'll do five years fully
guaranteed I'm about to sell the team
I'll give the league office the middle
finger on the way out the door they
don't like five year fully guaranteed
contracts I'll give him one so I it'll
it'll be interesting to see if someone
does it because I think if they if they
can get one of these other teams can get
Lamar to sign something other than five
years fully guaranteed maybe the Ravens
match it somebody does it to Sean Watson
deal
it could be gone
Geno Smith that's a win-win for both
sides I would think uh I don't know how
much leverage he had what did you make
of Gino and the Seahawks well I mean
bottom line is if they don't do that
deal they have to use the franchise tag
or let him hit the open market and I
don't know what kind of a land rush
there would have been for Geno Smith
because it was one year he had those
eight years in the wilderness I think
it's a great stat he made 17 and a half
million his entire career before this
contract this new contract pays twice
that per year and and a cautionary note
and this is more relevant to the Derek
Carr contract because we've seen the
real details that first headline that
comes out
is almost always
got a little BS baked into it I haven't
seen the Geno contract details yet but
three years 105
may be taking a liberty or two with the
truth maybe it's a two-year deal and
it's look that's a fascinating wrinkle
Dan because you got Pete Carroll out
there making noise about using the fifth
overall pick on a quarterback now either
that's just posturing to maybe trade out
or it's real the real details of the
Geno Smith contract will show us whether
they are making a three-year commitment
but if if what's been reported is
accurate 35 million a year for a guy who
was forgotten that's a damn good Payday
for him
I'm confused with the Daniel Jones
situation of what he reportedly wants
and if I'm the Giants
I I let somebody come and get Daniel
Jones and give me uh two first-round
picks for him that I I I can't go up to
45 but 32 sounds like a pretty good deal
for a guy who's had one really good year
how do you think this plays out
yeah and Dan when this news broke a
couple of weeks ago that he had changed
agencies from CAA to athletes first I
mean this isn't like he traded in some
mom-and-pop operation for a high-end
agency he went from one high-end agency
to another so if CAA didn't get him 45
million a year or more from the Giants
athletes first isn't going to get it
either especially when the Giants have
the franchise tag at 32.4 you do it 32.4
this year see what he does if he's
really good again tag him again next
year at a 20 increase you're still at 36
million per year for two years not 45
and here's the other side of it you know
the Kirk Cousins path is two free agency
or two franchise tags excuse me and then
you go because the third year it's a 44
raise over the second year well you know
what the Giants could do that with
Daniel Jones pay him 54 million in 2025
and the average would still be 42
million a year for the three years so
why would they ever yeah give him
anything close to that just go year to
year under the franchise tag and I fully
expect that that he'll be tagged today
when you get to this stage of the game
Dan if you're the player it's better to
get tagged because you still have until
July 15 to do your long-term deal take
the tag because the second time you're
tagged you get more money than you would
the first time the third time they just
in most cases can't do it so all these
guys who are looking at the tag today
they're better off just getting tagged
Mike Florio pro football talk live
co-host the show the precedes hours on
peacock what do you think Aaron Rodgers
says today to Pat McAfee about his
future
well we are 52 weeks to the day from
when Aaron Rodgers announced that he was
staying with the Packers and he said
he's not going to hold the Packers
hostage I think it kind of already is in
a passive aggressive fashion because
he's like oh why does anybody need to
know what I'm going to do well because
if they're going to trade you these
other teams need to know what they're
going to do the Jets need to know what
they're going to do if they're the team
that he's going to end up playing for
then I get the impression the Packers
are ready to move on when Brian
goodacunt's the GM of the team was asked
last week about the quarterback
situation he didn't say Aaron's our guy
as long as he wants to be here he said
Jordan love is absolutely ready to start
what's that tell you they would prefer
that he I believe choose to move on now
if he decides he wants to create chaos
and he says I'm here you owe me 60
million I know I don't have a no trade
clause but I'm going to make it clear I
don't want to play for anybody else who
would trade for me if I make it clear I
don't want to play for anybody else then
they got a problem they're gonna have to
start him and maybe trade Jordan love or
or I I can't imagine they wouldn't play
him and pay him 60 million dollars but
and it's got It's got to happen soon
after today he is holding them hostage
he can't say he's not holding them
hostage after today because this is
basically the anniversary of when he let
them know last year he was staying but
they can't trade him without his
permission even though he has a no trade
clause no he doesn't have an no trade
clause but who's going to trade for him
I don't think he has a no trade plus it
doesn't matter to me starting
quarterback no one is trading for a
starting quarterback that doesn't want
to go to that team because you want a
guy who's going to show up early stay
late you don't want to bare minimum guy
even though he's kind of already a bare
minimum guy in Green Bay you don't want
a quarterback who doesn't want to be on
your team any other position you say hey
fine you know what just sit at home we
don't care if you're going to make the
investment in a quarterback he needs to
be all in so that's why I don't care
about no trade clause like yesterday
Derek Carr got into trade clause it
doesn't matter nobody's trading for that
contract if he doesn't want to go to
that team
yeah I'm just trying to figure out all
I'd want to know if I'm Green Bay is
Aaron do you want to play football that
that right help us start right there
right and then where would you want to
play because can Green Bay reach out to
the Jets or do they say to Aaron you are
free to you know find your passageway to
whatever Nirvana is start the process
well Trey Wingo reported late last night
early this morning that Rogers talked to
the Jets yesterday and that skips the
step of Rogers getting permission to
talk to anybody and you would think last
week in Indianapolis somebody would have
caught wind of the fact that the Packers
had given Aaron Rodgers permission to
talk to other teams that's a pretty
significant story that we in the media
business would like to report and make a
little money off of frankly so it's odd
that we go from nothing to he's talking
to the Jets and maybe they did maybe
they did keep that middle step Under
Wraps I don't know but if if that
report's accurate he he's talking to the
Jets and we'll see what's going to
happen but Dan I I'm having a hard time
and Sims and I talk about this almost
every day who really wants this guy
right now and everything that goes along
with him he's taken that heel turn over
the past couple of years he's not going
to be as popular it's not going to be
like bringing Brady and I mean you take
a Brady number 12 jersey and a Rogers
number 12 Jersey with a new team same
team Brady's going to sell a hell of a
lot more of them than Aaron Rodgers
right now
yeah if I'm the Jets
um I I would have gone after Derek Carr
uh like I liked four years that I know
I'm getting four years as opposed to I'm
getting one and then am I getting
another one and then what goes along
with that with Aaron and obviously he's
a better quarterback but I I have to I
mean I got to think about the stability
of a young team you know somebody who's
going to provide leadership and I do
look back at what Derek Carr did with
the Raiders on a team that perennially
had terrible defenses and he's still you
know hung in there when they had that
year of disaster he he had a you know he
rideed the ship so I I would rather have
that than I would you know Aaron and the
potential that he brings along with him
hey hey Dan you're going to commit the
60 million for this year alone as he
walks through the door and you're going
to give the Packers something to get him
and you don't know whether he's going to
be there after this year and okay fine
off-season program starts in April is he
is he going to show up or not because
what have we seen the past couple of
years in Green Bay he doesn't show up
and then we wonder why he doesn't click
with his receivers until November I mean
I thought the guy was smart look at
Patrick Mahomes last year Tyree kills
gone what did he do he went above and
beyond he took the guys to Texas he
worked with his guys on his own he sent
notes to Andy Reed about what guys do
well Aaron Rodgers standoffish aloof
absent and and what happens these new
guys who grew up in all of Aaron Rodgers
didn't get comfortable until November
and they came within a week of making
the playoffs so if he's going to play
for the Jets the Packers whoever I need
to know this guy is all in and if I'm
the Jets I
I'm very concerned about it and look
Tiki Barber made this point a couple of
weeks ago he knows that New York media
Market Aaron Rodgers in the New York
media first press conference you think
they're going to tiptoe around him the
way they have in Green Bay for the last
15 years hell no I and I'm kind of
rooting for that because I like a little
chaos but I I just there's a lot you
know it it may feel really good on the
way in for jets fans
it could get Rocky quickly Rich Eisen
was tap dancing yesterday a little bit
he was talking about rumors that he
heard at the combine and and Rich knows
this or you should know this that even
if you put out a rumor that you heard it
becomes a report it doesn't take long
for that where somebody does put it into
context and Rich was saying hey you know
what Brady's retired and everybody's
moved on and but you know this is like
bar talk where he was like you know what
dolphins Tom Brady wouldn't rule that
out okay there's nothing to substantiate
that
so how do you deal with a rumor like
well it's funny and and I don't want to
speak out of school but I spoke to Rich
last night because I wanted to make sure
I properly couched what he said and what
he didn't say look at you he was very
reticent about you know I don't want to
do this I said dude I've been doing this
for 22 years it's okay it it actually
works we're trying to set the narratives
we're trying to push the envelope it's
okay embrace it but but he he was very
clear yeah he's not saying that Brady's
telling people he's going to play he's
not doing any of that stuff he's just
passing along things he heard in Indy
and Dan how can there not be a sense
that maybe Brady is going to come back
we've seen it with farv we saw it with
Brady last year even though I think he
knew damn well he was playing in 2022
when he retired this year though he
could pass a lie detector test right now
are you retired yes I am
come June he may feel differently come
July he may feel differently the most
telling fact to me
and one of the episodes of his podcast
after he retired Jim Gray said to him
you once said you would retire when you
suck you don't suck why are you retiring
and he said I believed it when I said it
that is a great get out of jail free
card I believed it when I said it I'm
not lying I mean George Costanza should
have embraced this I wasn't lying I
believed it when I said it you can you
can have a lot of power in that
statement so I'm not ready to believe we
won't see him he is Mike Florio the new
mob novel father of mine now available
for pre-order hits bookshelves April
25th 4.99 less than a pack of smokes
4.99 I love giving them away yeah
uh great great to talk to you thank you
Mike thanks Mike Florio pro football
talk live co-host